I grew up in a small village.
That's why I think America is too big for me.
There are a lot of families in Iran that are not like my family
when the compulsory hijab was applied on women
some families started to cry for their daughters.
As a kid my brother was an example of freedom
freedom--was a symbol of freedom that
I didn't have.  How was free to run
in a green, lovely farm;
how was free to ride a bicycle in a nice
village... my village is the best!
Just look at them.
I love that
Two women with head scarves, and two women without head scarves.
look at how they are free. They just, you know, walk past each other
without judging each other. Without getting arrested by the morality police.
Isn't that beautiful? I want to see this in my own country.
I started to publish this one: It's me, and me.
So that's why people started to send their pictures and I ask women to
sharing experiences which they did.
Women who take pictures of themselves, outside, in Iran
without their headscarves
which is a punishable crime.
every individual
story makes me really happy
there are a lot of women sending their
pictures
holding a sign saying that "we believe in hijab, but we hate compulsory hijab"
Some of the pictures come from those
young girls saying that they just want to feel the wind in their hair. It's a simple demand.
Like this. It's forbidden. To be like this is forbidden in Iran.
They take off their scarf in front of these signs.
This is the "Proper Islamic Hijab"
There are a lot of pictures that you can see men supporting women.
All the women in my family, they wear hijab.
This is not a black and white issue.
All families in Iran are not like my family. There are so many families in Iran
who do not believe in compulsory hijab.
Iran is for all Iranians. You cannot just hide one side of Iran and say "this is Iran"
This is a lie!
Iran is me and my mother.
my mother wants to wear a scarf. I do not want to wear a scarf.
Iran should be for both of us.